clay Pollan tunas ESPN Brazil I just
asked Steph Curry about the bond a guy
shared being the splash brothers and
everything he he just said that in some
practice sessions you guys will have
some friendly competitions where you'll
be on one side he'll be on the other and
they'll kind of peek over and kind of
root against you a little bit there can
you speak to that like what kind of bond
you guys have and the friendly
competition they guys share on the
practice court I mean he's been a great
teammate
for eight years even a better friend and
you root for guys like Steph because he
doesn't take any shortcuts he works
extremely hard he's a family man and
he's just a you know a prime example of
what you want your leader to be a huge
ambassador to community and hopefully
you know we can go down it's one of the
greater back horse ever play and
obviously it's been a very beneficial
partnership for both of us and I could
imagine playing with any other point
guard cuz we got such a great chemistry
we know each other's favorite spots
where we want the ball and yeah I'm just
thankful to share the backcourt with him
because he such a selfless amazing
competitor and teammate but the splash
brothers nickname is that is that
something they a bond that is that is
that a cool thing yeah super guys yeah
okay